head of instagram adam moseri is set to
testify on capitol hill today about
social media's impact on teenagers a
whistleblower accused instagram's parent
company formerly known as facebook of
being aware of harmful effects on kids
mental health chris van cleeve is on
capitol hill chris good morning
good morning missori is testifying for
the first time before congress and he's
expected to highlight some of the new
features that the company says will make
instagram safer for teens ahead of
today's hearing instagram announced the
new features including updated parental
controls and reminders for teens to take
breaks the senators leading today's
hearing say instagram's new efforts fall
short
we know that they are researching this
we know that they have chosen not to
take steps that would stop
some of this content not only do they
know
that their destructive content is
driving kids down these rabbit holes to
eating disorders and self-harm even
suicide
but they're profiting from it
today's hearing comes just months after
a facebook whistleblower francis haugen
turned over internal documents appearing
to show the social media company was
aware the app may cause depression and
anxiety especially for some teenage
girls instagram insists the research is
being mischaracterized senators richard
blumenthal and martha marsha blackburn
are working on drafting legislation that
will provide better protection for kids
and teens and may also require social
media apps to be more transparent
missouri is expected to say that
instagram will support some new
regulation tony
we'll be watching chris thank you very
much